さて、みんなここでドガンして
、日本語の先生があなたの日本語を採点する最初のエピソードへようこそ、
または
私がここで新しい人のためにこのビデオを呼んでしまうものは何でも、私の名前
はドゲンです。
m
このシリーズを作成して
、もう少し頻繁にyoutubeにアップロードし、日本語でコメディックコンテンツ
を作成することに加えて、新しいコンテンツを試してみます。
日本語の発音とパトレオンのピッチアクセントも教えて
います。これは、私が得た知識を使って行います。
ワシントン大学
とコ大学で
日本語を学び、日本語の日本語を勉強
しました。ここでこれらの本の情報の一部を使ってい
ます。これらは
すべて日本語の日本語の本
です。 アクセントなので、自分の資格を見せようとしているだけで
、自分の日本語を自慢しようとはして
いません。
過去のeビデオでも10分かけ
て自分の日本語の問題を超えて長々と話し
ていますが、トピックについてはかなり知って
いるので、興味があれば日本語の一部を修正したいと思いました。
私が見たい最初のビデオ
はノアからのものです
ので、そのビデオをプルアップし
て、日本人が
大丈夫に対してコンニチワであることをどのように知って
いるかを見てみましょう。
顔を合わせてビデオを提出していただきありがとうございます。実際に
そこ
にいると、他の人が見やすくなり
、実際の人
がいて、素晴らしいマイクを使用している場合は、より面白くなります。
これは素晴らしいです
全体的にあなたは
非常に自然な方法
で日本語を話しますそしてそれが意味するのはあなたの
一般的なマナー
とあなたが話すときあなたが
あなたの考えを明確にするとき
あなたは私が信じるような方法で話すということです
ほとんどの日本人は
、あなたが日本語を話し、あなたと会話するのを聞いて非常に快適に感じるでしょう。
聞いている多くの人にとって、
それは実際には、ノアの特定の要素のように、彼が彼について話していないことを意味しないと思うかもしれません。
発音ですが
、このレッスンの後半で
、ページのアクセントと発音の詳細に関する実際の音声学の観点からこの点に戻ります。ここで
は説明しない小さなことがいくつかあります。
主にそれらは次の理由によるものです。
大阪で日本語を勉強したとおっしゃっていましたが
、大阪では高低アクセントのシステムが標準の高低アクセントとは
違うので
、
高低アクセントの間違いの中には、
実際には高低アクセントの間違いではないものもあると思います。
大阪では違うので、例えば、
昨日
の標準的な日本語の単語は
、「いいえ」にアクセントが付いたキノですが、私は岡を信じています。
キーにアクセントを付けたino私
は通常、
日本人学習者
が関西でまだ勉強していない場合、または
まだ留学していないが勉強する場合は、長期的にできるだけ自然に聞こえたい場合に奨励します
海外で普通の日本語を
使っているところに行くのは、
彼らがすでにCDなどから学んでいる
日本人が99歳
の時の普通の日本人だからです。
明らかに彼はすでに大阪に行った
ことがあるので、
そうすることができます。 そのような修正はしませ
んが、ノアの場合について話したい具体的なこと
は、
日本語を話しているのは
、高低アクセントではなく強勢アクセント言語であるかのように聞こえるということです。
言語だから
私はこれについて過去に話しました
が、
英語は強勢アクセント言語ですこの
アクセントは強勢から来ているので、これは
私が単語を言うときはいつでも
その単語のアクセント部分
が長いことを意味します 少し
大きくて
、他のビット
よりもピッチが高いので、
明日という言葉を言うと、
これがデフォルトの単語です。明日はいつも明日使用します
。maは明日右
の単語の他のビットよりも少し長いです。
また、音量も大きく、
ピッチも高くなりますが
、これは英語が再び強勢
アクセント
言語であるためです。
一方、日本語のアクセントは高低
アクセント言語である
ため、ピッチは高低アクセントや高低アクセントではなくアクセントに
なります。
と長さなので、たとえば
日本語の箸の単語は
オハシで、ホップ
は周囲のビットよりも少し高いですが
、暑いのは
周囲のビットより長くはなく
、通常は他のビットよりも大きくはありませ
ん。
アクセントを決定するピッチの違いピッチアクセント
大橋ではなく
大橋大橋ではなく
大橋だからこれは私が
できる主なもののように聞こえます ええと
、あなたが日本語を大幅に上達させるために取り組むことができることについて、あなたの日本語について正確に指摘します。
ほんの少しの作業で、これは
あなたの場合に大きな違いを
生み、いくつかの詳細を
与えると思います。
私が
住んでいる九州の地域ではそうですねが、
あのなと言っていたと思いますので、さっそく
聞いてみましょう。
これは実は良い例な
ので、少し長すぎます。
アクセントをつけているように聞こえますが、日本語のuhの長
さのアクセントで通常はほぼフラットなフレーズ
は、実際
には他の単語とは異なる単語になる可能性があるため、
1つの良い例は、
夢の単語と
有名な夢の単語です。 あなたは私を意味しました
が、有名なのはあなたが
単語の特定の
要素に長すぎると、実際には単語
の意味を根本的に変える可能性がある
ので
、あなたが話しているように聞こえるので、
もう一度 高低アクセント言語のようなもので
、特定の場合に誤解を招く可能性があり
ます。
日本人が
あなたの特定のケースを聞いているとき、私
が最も気づいているの
は、日本語は 強
勢アクセント
言語
や一般的な日本語ではなく、高低アクセント言語は、英語ほどの力やパンチはありません。これも、強勢ではなく
、それに気づいて積極的に耳
を傾ければ、高低アクセントです。
一般的に、ごくわずかな時間で
本当に良い成果が得られると思います。あなたの発音はとても
良い
と思います。また、レッスンの後半でこれについて話し
ます。とても簡単です。
あなたの言うことを聞いてください。日本人が日本語であなたと会話
するのはとても簡単だと思います
が、あなたが最高の場所に行こうとしているのなら
、発音とピッチの点であなたはそうすることができます
アクセント
よく高低アクセントは少し
複雑です。もう一度
大阪にいたのですが
、ストレスアクセントではなく高低アクセントの観点から
考えてみてください。
あなたは自分よりも良い場所にいると思います。
えーと、
ノアの日本人を見たので、
ハルサンの外国語をチェックしてみましょう
[音楽]
あなたの発音は本当に良いので、これは本当に面白いでしょう
が、
2つの主なものがたくさんあると思います
多くの人がこのビデオから学ぶことができると思います
最初のものは実際には高低
アクセントですこれは
ノア
が大阪にいて、
大阪もまったく異なるピッチを持っているので、ノアではあまり対処できなかったものです
アクセントシステム
ですが、あなたの場合は、
主に小説やマンガから学んだ
と言っていて、アニメもたくさんあると思います。
教室から日本語を勉強し
たので、あなたの発音は
とても良い発音です。私はあなたが素晴らしい道を進んでいると思うので
、あなたの発音については何も言わないほうがいい
と思い
ます。
高低アクセントに関していくつかのことがあると言って、時間の経過とともにスムーズになると思うことを過度に意識させたくあり
ません。私はあなたに指摘したいのですが、
それはあなたのピッチのように聞こえます
あなたの心の中の事故のメカニズム
はまだアメリカの英語の規則に従って動作している
ので、これが私が
意味すること
ですアニメでは多くのアニメが
日本で設定されて
いるので、多くの人がそれを聞いてそれから 彼ら
は、日本語の高低アクセントが日本語であると誤って想定していると思い込んでいます。その
アクセントは、日本語の
場合と同じように発生します。
実際に、これについてのビデオ全体を作成し
ました。 過去は、1分で
日本の日本人と日本人の言い方のように呼ばれていまし
た。これは
よくある間違いです。これもまた
、nihongoではありませんが、nihongoではありませんが、あなたの発音
は再び壮観
ですが、nihongoと言っているからです。
このビデオ全体で何度も
試してみて、それらの本当の速さを見つけましょう。
これは、最初の音節にアクセントを付けて偽の名前を先に言ったときに
、あなたの心のメカニズムがまだ
アメリカの高低アクセント規則を順守
していることのかなり良い証拠です
が、これは例です 実際の高低アクセントがある単語の場合
、アクセントがないので、
遅いスピーチでは低音で始まり、高低アクセントの
ように高くなりますが、速い
スピーチで
は、ある種の良いヒントのようにほぼフラットになります。
本当に良いグラフ
この本のどこにあるのか正確に
忘れてしまいました。皆さんはこれを見ることができないので、
すぐに分解し
ますが、日本語の3つのモーラまたは3つのビートの単語すべての
52％はアクセントがない
ので、これは
日本人の先生
が生徒に
日本語がフラットだとよく言う理由の1つです。これは、日本語には
アクセントのない単語がたくさんあるからです。
あなたが言ったようなアクセントがありますそれはアクセントを持って
いる単語の本当に良い例です
それは
shiですがそれがあなたの場合に
私が話したい主なことを言っていない他の多くの単語があり
ます
高低アクセントの
知識
が少しあれば、発音が本当に良いので、音声で話すのは素晴らしい場所になります。
私が日本語を勉強していたときの発音よりも確かに良いと思い
ます。
確かに数年
経ち
ますが、高低アクセントの
基本的なことや
、あなたが犯した多くの間違いを学んだら、rの発音のように私の日本語にはまだ多くの問題が
あります。 給料小切手に関連する日本の音声学
の領域にはたくさんの良い規則があり、
それがすぐ
にあなたの話す日本語の音を
はるかに自然にするので
、そこに少しの知識があるだけで
あなたは再びあなたになるでしょうから、二度と作ることはありません」
私が話したいもう一つの主要なことは、あなたが大きく飛躍する
でしょう。このビデオの興味深い点の一種になると思い
ます。あなたの口に言葉を入れたくない
ので、私が行くことは 今やる
べきことは、私が日本語を勉強していたときのいくつかの逸話をあげるつもりです。
私が若い
頃、あなたが日本語を話しているときにあなたが何を考えているのかわからないので
、私が
聞いたとき あなたの日本語それは私
が日本語についてどう思った
か、そして私が若い頃に再び日本語を話す方法を私に思い出させ
ました私はまた私が教室でそれを勉強する前に何年も自分で日本語を勉強
したので私は
たくさんの日本語のテレビを見ていました
一組の本と一組の
中古
書店のカセット
テープのように、2、3年くらい聞いた日本語を全部買ったのですが、
それはすべて
ネイティブの日本人
だったので、自然ではない入力はありませんでした。多くの
人が教室でダンクするのが好きです。
なぜなら、私は過去にもこれを行ったことがあります。なぜなら、私は
外国人が日本語を話そうとしているのを聞くのが好きでは
なく、ネイティブの日本語をまっすぐに聞くのではなく
、その意味でアニメから日本語を学ぶの
は素晴らしいことです。
アニメで聞く日本人はいつも
100自然ですアニメで間違ったピッチアクセントや間違った発音を聞くことは決してないだろう
と言ったアニメも
ある程度真空状態に
あり、最近これが
おそらく出てくると思うので 私の友人のマット対
日本は、アニメから日本語を学ぶことについてのビデオを作りました、
そして私は
彼
が私がちょうどすべての日本について述べた他のいくつかの点に同意したことに同意するだろうと
思います
アニメから聞いたものは
ネイティブで、その意味
で彼が作ったビデオ全体を見たことが
ないので
、この特定の点ですべてについて100に同意することはできないかもしれません
が、
マットは賢い人です。 彼は私が言おうとし
ていることなしに矛盾するいくつかの
ことを言います
そして私は私たちの両方が言っていることに耳を傾け
、その
アニメのようなものがある程度真空に存在し
、しばしばあなたがそうしないことに基づいてあなたの決心をします 日本人
の文化的側面のように多くの
ことを学び、アニメを見ることからいわば日本人について学ぶ
ので、私が若い頃からその逸話に戻ると
、私が学んだ日本人の多く
はまっすぐだったので ソースは
それらのカセットテープからのアニメからのネイティブスピーチ
でした、そして私は
外国人が日本語を話そうとしているのを聞いたことがありませんでした
私
は初めて日本の
教室
に行ったとき私の日本語にかなり自信がありました
当時、日本語を勉強していたのは
オレンジデイズオレンジ
デザートというシリーズで、あのシリーズの
中
には
、キャラクターの主人公がそういうことを言うと恥ずかしくないって言ってくれるシーンがあります。
私は非常に恥ずかしいです、そして
彼が言う日本語のフレーズは私がそうだと思います
um iiは
その時私が多くのリソースを持っていなかったのでその特定のエピソードを何度も繰り返し見ていまし
た
、それはフレーズの1つでした それは
私の心に染み込んでいるようなもの
で、日本語の
教室の先生は学生のよう
にあなたの週末はどうだったのか
と尋ねていたので、彼女は私に好きなように尋ねました、
そして私がそれに応えて彼女に
言ったことは私が良い発音でそれを言ったということ
でした かなり良い高低アクセントです
が、音声で言えば私の
高低アクセントと発音は
本当に良かっ
たのですが、それは実際に
は日本語であなたの先生と話すのに本当に本当に失礼
な方法です。
日本と日本の文化では、
学生と教師の間
は西洋よりもはるかに明確に定義されている
ので、私が言ったとき
、私の先生はすぐに
本当に厳しい
口調で
私に言ったので、そのように私に話しかけないでください あなたがし
ていること
は大きな間違いですそのように私に話さないでください
そしてそれは面白かった
です その
設定と多くの私は、
彼らの日本語
の高低アクセントと
発音が私のものよりもはるかに悪かったと言うことができ
ましたが、同時に、彼らは
礼儀正しい日本語ではない日本語を一度も取り上げたことがあり
ませんでした。
教室で教えられたので、他の人が
犯している間違いを聞くことができ、他の言葉をたくさん知っていたので、私はこの設定に入るのに非常に自信がありませんでした。
私が知っているこのフレーズを使うの
は、
教育を受けた賢い人のように聞こえ、100％
は長い
間、すべての
ジャブのように完全に裏目に出て、新しい日本人に会うたび
に、私のように話す
ようになります。
この
人が私の日本語がどれだけ上手かを知っているように話そうと思った
ので、もう一度言います。
私はまた、
あなたの日本語の発音がとても良いことを知って
いると言って、日本人の友人がいました。
この人はバイリンガルだったので、話すと
別のキャラクターのようになります日本語を話すと、ネガティブな方法で別のキャラクターのようになると言われました
。
彼が私に言ったときあなたが言っ
ていることと私はそれを私
が教室で
一度叱責されたという事実と組み合わせて、
当時の私のガールフレンドが私に言っていたいくつかのことのように始めまし
た
違いの
ように、また日本の文化のさまざまな境界線のように、
私は日本語が本当に日本文化に根ざし
ているという事実に目覚め始めました、
そしてそれらの境界線
で私が話すことは再び非常に難しいです
あなたのために
ハルサム私は
あなたの考え方を知らないので私は
あなたがすでにたくさんのええと丁寧な日本語のようにあなたが知っているかもしれない
他の言葉を知りません 苔
の形ですが、
このような冗談めかしてビデオを始めたのは、まるで
日本語を勉強した
ことがあるので、そのビデオでの話し方がわからないかもしれません。
再び日本人を不快にさせるかもしれません。
だからこそ
、私がノアの日本語について話していたときに具体的に言ったの
です。 気持ち悪い
ので育てたい
と思いました。教室で日本語を学んでいる方もいらっしゃると思いますが、一人で
日本語を学んでいる方もいらっしゃると思います
が、それぞれの設定にはプラスとマイナスの要素があります。
主にアニメや
ドラマなどから日本語を独学で学んでいる人にとっては、叱責されたり、私が話していた境界線
を取得したりする機会がないことがよくあると思います。
多くの
場合、彼らは彼ら
に実際の日本語のネイティブ
スピーカーと
会うように明確
に教えられて
いません。
日本の文化的要素も
あり
ます。この分野で少し研究すれば、本当に
素晴らしい立場
になり、すぐにまたできると思います。
あなたの発音とあなたの
発音は壮観であり
、あなたのピッチアクセントは少しの作業で本当に良いでしょう
そしてそれを文化的な知識と組み合わせると
あなたは
このビデオのためにすぐに素晴らしい場所にいるでしょうそれは
すでにずっと長いです
このビデオを撮るのはこれが2回目であるにもかかわらず、
私が予想していたよりも、ここで物事を終わらせるつもり
ですが、あなたが私がしたのと同じようにあなたの日本語を修正したいのであれば
このビデオ
を送信してください。
私と連絡を取るための最善の方法は
、ビデオをTwitterで送信し、
Twitter
にビデオを埋め込んで、すぐに視聴できるようにして
から、そのビデオへのダウンロードリンクを含めることです。
動画に字幕を含めることができれば、動画
を選択する可能性が高くなります
。日本人がいるので
、非常に高いレベルの日本語を視聴している人
もいますが、他の人もいます。
彼らが日本語を学び始めたばかり
で、これらのビデオのスピーカーが何を
言っている
のか正確
にわからないかもしれません。
日本人の先生があなたが日本人かドーガンだと評価しますあなたが日本人
です